Speaker 1: Let's go next to Oh, let's go to
our old old friend Isa from London.
Isa, how are you?
Good, how are you?
I'm doing well and what's going on.
All COVID guidelines are being ended there,
is that right?
Speaker 5: Yeah, that's right.
Yeah, they they scrapped everything.
But you know, I don't know if you keep up
with UK politics much.
There's, you know, much, much bigger issues
with our government.
So right now, the whole whole lot going on,
you know?
Speaker 1: Yes, indeed.
And mean, are you referring to the Boris Johnson
COVID party stuff or what?
Speaker 5: Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
You know, there's there's new, new things
from the past that, you know, get brought
up every day.
But today's topic, I guess this is Johnson.
Yeah, but go ahead.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, I was going to say this a thought I
was having.
Aaron Rodgers said his stuff about people
rooting against Green Bay because of his vaccine
status.
Yes, I think I feel like what happened to
Rogers is the same thing that happened to
Rogan, which was going to happen on a much
larger scale.
And what I mean is he came out and he said
all his stuff right about vaccines and how
he wouldn't take them and how he encourages
young people not to get them.
And then he caught COVID and everyone clowned
him for that so badly that it kind of led
him to snap.
Hmm.
If you understand where I'm coming from, yeah,
it basically tipped him over the edge.
And ever since then?
His whole persona, his personality has been
COVID vaccines, leftists, woke mob, cancel
culture, mainstream media, CNN and even even
the guests he brings on his shows.
They just people that he can circlejerk with
about how right he is to reaffirm himself.
Hmm.
So, yeah, I was just wondering what you think
about that?
Speaker 1: Well, I ended up, you know, when
I talked about Aaron Rodgers, the NFL football
player, saying people were rooting against
us because of my vaccine status, I guess.
And I said, that's true to some degree.
I gave it more thought.
I think that there's actually more to it.
I think people some people were rooting against
Aaron Rodgers because the entire COVID thing
made him look like a know it all prick.
And that's what a lot of people were kind
of reacting to, more so than the fact that
he's unvaccinated per say.
Yeah.
In terms of the rogue and stuff, I mean, listen.
I know the guy a little bit, and I believe
him when he says he's not trying to spread
disinformation, he believes the stuff that
the guests say.
I do believe that I don't think he's trying
to spread disinformation.
I just think he is.
And I think part of it is we know that since
he's moved to Texas, at least somewhat, he
hangs out with the wacky Republican governor
Greg Abbott.
You know, he's in that.
He's in a circle where I think what's going
on around him is very reactionary and radical.
And even without bad intentions, I think he's
just been captured by a lot of the stuff.
I'm not excusing anything he's done.
I think the stuff that's gone out on his show
is terrible, but I believe him when when he
says he's not malicious in trying to spread
disinformation, I think it's coming from a
place of ignorance.
Speaker 5: Yeah.
Yeah, that's fair enough.
I mean, you've you've been on his show twice,
you you know him, so.
Yeah, that's fair.
It just seemed to me that ever since the whole
Kobe thing happened, he his ego, I guess,
has been wounded deeply.
Speaker 1: So it's possible I can't speak
to that, but it's certainly possible that
this was going on.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Cool.
All right, Lisa from London.
Thank you so much for the call.
Great to hear from
you again, of
course